STEVE: WELCOME BACK TO FOX &
FRIENDS.
FORMER ACTING SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE CHRISTOPHER MILLER IS
JOINING CALLS FOR GENERAL MARK
MILLEY TO RESIGN OVER ACCUSATION
S HE HAD SECRET PHONE
CALLS WITH CHINA.
MILLER TELLING FOX NEWS, "I DID
NOT AND WOULD NOT EVER AUTHORIZE
SUCH CONDUCT."
AINSLEY: MEANWHILE PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS STANDING BEHIND THE
GENERAL SAYING GENERAL
MILLEY HAS GREAT, HE HAS GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN GENERAL MILLEY.
BRIAN:  RETIRED ARMY GENERAL BIG
A DEER GENERAL I SHOULD SAY
JOINS US NOW, GENERAL, WHOSE
RIGHT HERE?
GENERAL JACK KEANE WHO SAID TO
FOX YESTERDAY, HE TAKES MILLEY
AT HIS WORD AND CALLED HIS
ACTIONS RESPONSIBLE?
OR  SO MANY OTHERS?
>> I BELIEVE HIS ACTIONS ARE
IRRESPONSIBLE AND THEY FALL
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TREASON OF
DUTY, WE NEVER WOULD TOLERATE
THAT IN OUR SUBORDINATE OFFICERS
WE WOULD REMOVE THEM IMMEDIATELY
, LT. COLONEL SHELLER
, RECENT EXAMPLES
THIS IS, I AM BEING REACHED OUT
TO BY MANY PEOPLE IN THE
MILITARY WHO HAVE LOST
CONFIDENCE IN THE CHAIRMAN.
THERE’S A PERCEPTION OUT THERE
THAT HE DID THIS.
HE NEEDS TO DO THE RIGHT THING,
HAVE SOME MORAL COURAGE, STEP
ASIDE, WE NEED TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION AND HE NEEDS TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS
EITHER TREASON OR
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN DERELICTION
OF DUTY.
STEVE: GENERAL, JOE BIDEN AND
THE WHITE HOUSE SAY WE STAND BY
GENERAL MILLEY, BUT IF GENERAL
MILLEY DID THIS TO JOE BIDEN,
YOU GOT TO FIGURE, HE PROBABLY
BE FIRED BY NOON.
>> OH, THERE BE NO DOUBT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD HAVE FIRED
HIM.
I WOULD ASSUME IT WOULD HAVE NOT
TAKEN UNTIL NOON, RIGHT?
AND RIGHTLY SO.
THIS IS A LOSS OF CONFIDENCE.
HOW MANY TIMES ARE WE GOING TO
LOSE CONFIDENCE IN THIS GUY?
FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE HAVE A
BORDER SECURITY SITUATION WHICH
THE MILITARY HAS TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR BORDER
SECURITY IS FAILING RIGHT NOW.
THE WITHDRAWAL IN AFGHANISTAN
WAS A DISASTER.
THE POLICY, MILITARY STRATEGY
LEADING UP TO THE WITHDRAWAL WAS
A DISASTER AND NOW, WE HAVE
THESE PHONE CALLS TO COUNTERPART
S.
I TALK TO MANY OF MY COUNTERPART
S AS A DIVISION LEVEL
COMMANDER, SPECIAL OPERATIONS
COMMAND AFRICA AND NEVER WOULD
IT HAVE ENTERED MY MIND TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS LIKE THIS.
WE HAVE TO DEVELOP THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS.
THEY ARE NECESSARY, BUT THIS ,
IF TRUE, IS TREASONIST OR  AT
THE LEAST, DERELICTION OF DUTY.
AINSLEY: THAT’S WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAID TOO.
HE SAID IF IT IS TRUE IT’S
TREASON.
I KNOW THAT YOU’VE CALLED FOR
MILLEY’S RESIGNATION MANY
TIMES.
YOU SAY YOU KNOW HOW HE OPERATES
AS A POLITICALLY-DRIVEN GENERAL.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> WELL I’VE WATCHED HIM OVER
THE YEARS AND I’VE WATCHED MANY
OF THE GENERALS AND MOST OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS, THEY’RE IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW.
THEY CHANGE THEIR COLORS.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THEM STARTED
OFF WITH GEORGE BUSH, TRANSITION
ED OVER TO PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND BOUGHT OFF ON ALL THE
BAD POLICY IN AFRICA,
AFGHANISTAN, IRAQ, SYRIA, ALL
OVER THE WORLD THAT WEAKENED
AMERICA’S POSITION WITH THEIR
ALLIES.
THEN THEY TRANSITION TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHICH I KNEW BE
DIFFICULT FOR ALL OF THEM.
APPARENTLY IT HAS, BECAUSE THEY
UNDERMINED HIM BEHIND HIS BACK,
AND THEN THEY GO BACK TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO HAS
DEMONSTRATED HOW IT’S AN IN
COMPETENT ADMINISTRATION,
AND WE ARE IN A LOT OF TROUBLE
ECONOMICALLY, FISCALLY, IN THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
AMERICANS AND I AM AFRAID FOR
OUR REPUTATION AND FOR OUR
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS ON THE
GROUND IN MANY PLACES OF THE
WORLD.
BRIAN:  IF YOU’RE AFRAID THEN
WE’RE AFRAID, BUT THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT CHINA’S GOING TO GET A
HEADS UP IF WE BOMB THEM SO
THAT’S GOOD TO KNOW, THAT THAT
WAR COLLEGE CLASS IS GOING TO BE
IN SESSION.
APPRECIATE IT, GENERAL.
WE HEAR YOUR ALARM.
>> WELL, I HOPE AMERICANS DO
AND I HOPE THEY CALL FOR HIM TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
I KNOW OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
BELIEVE THERE’S A PERCEPTION,
PERCEPTION CAN BE REALITY.
IT’S ONE OF THE RULES OF A
LEADER, AND IF YOU’RE NOT
OPERATING EFFECTIVELY AND YOU’RE
HURTING YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOU
NEED TO STEP ASIDE.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, GENERAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AINSLEY: THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE